[Musique]
si vous êtes ici vous savez déjà qui
elle est
lidiatar est multiple
[Musique]
tard a commencé sa carrière de chef
d'orchestre avec l'orchestre de
Cleveland l'Orchestre symphonique de
Chicago l'Orchestre symphonique de
Boston jusqu'à ce qu'elle arrive enfin
ici chez nous au philharmonique de New
York en 2013 Berlin a choisi tard comme
chef d'orchestre permanente et c'est
là-bas qu'elle est restée depuis lors
lédiatar a également écrit de la musique
pour le théâtre et le cinéma elle fait
partie des 15 que l'on appelle les
egottes ceux qui ont remporté les quatre
récompenses majeures dans le domaine du
spectacle merci d'être parmi merci à
vous madame
la composition ça va
pas trop bien les notes deviennent des
soins
à se sensibiliter au beau
est-ce qu'il vous arrive sentir par
moment que l'émotion vous submerge oui
oui effectivement
[Musique]
on a un problème
j'ai encore reçu un message bizarre
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on se retrouve
Méli à cette affaire
[Musique]
je m'inquiète elle se recroque fiche sur
elle-même
si tu veux prendre par balle il faut que
tu sers de compositeur tu dois te
sublimer toi ton ego et oui ton identité
[Musique]
tu dois te tenir devant le public et
devant Dieu
[Musique]